مرحبا بكم نتابع الاخبار العاجله الوارده
من تل ابيب حيث تتحدث وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه عن مقتل اسرائيلي واصابه اثنين
على الاقل في هجوم لمسلح فلسطيني اطلق
النار على اسرائيليين في قلبي تل ابيب
والقناه الثالثه عشره الاسرائيليه تتحدث
عن مقتل منفذ عمليه اطلاق النار في قلبي
تل ابيب
الشارع الذي وقعت فيه عمليه اطلاق النار
شارع ديزنكوف ووسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
تتحدث عن اصابه شخصين في اطلاق النار وسط
تل ابيب في حين قتل منفذ العمليه دائما
وفقا لما تذكره وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
وعلى اثر ذلك
بدات تطلق دعوات من مسؤولين سياسيين في
اسرائيل تطالب بوقف الاحتجاجات الشعبيه
المناهضه
للتعديلات القضائيه التي اقترحتها الحكومه
في ضوء هذه التطورات الميدانيه في تل ابيب
احد
المصابين في هذه العمليه تقول المعلومات
ان جروحه حرجه على كل المزيد من التفاصيل
مع الياس كران
ليحدثنا اكثر عن تفاصيل هذه العمليه الياس
نعم بالفعل عمليه على خلفيه قوميه كما
تؤكد المصادر الاسرائيليه ومصادر الشرطه
الاسرائيليه ونحن نتحدث عن قلبي تل ابيب
احد المراكز او الشوارع الرئيسيه والهامه
في مدينه تل ابيب شارع ديزنجو هذا الشارع
الذي كان شهد في الانتفاضه الثانيه الكثير
من العمليات التفجيريه في الحافلات وايضا
في المواقع مختلفه استهدفت فيها مقاهن
بعمليات اطلاق نار هذه العمليه تاتي في
هذه الساعه المتاخره من هذا المساء في
قلبي كما اشرت احد المناطق المقتضعه عاده
بالاسرائيليين في مثل هذه الساعه ونحن
نتحدث ايضا عن يوم شهدت فيه مدينه تل ابيب
احتجاجات شعبيه عارمه بمعنى ان الشوارع
كانت مقتظه بالاسرائيليين ساعه وقوع
العمليه المعلومات المتوفره هذه الساعه من
مصادر الاسعاف الاسرائيلي تشير الى ان
هنالك ثلاثه اصابات في صفوف الاسرائيليين
احدى هذه الاصابات خطيره اخرى متوسطه وشخص
اخر اصيب بجروح طفيفه فيما اكدت مصادر
الشرطه الاسرائيليه بان منفذ العمليه الذي
كما يبدو من الصور التي
وردت الينا قد اطلق النار من مسدس باتجاه
الاسرائيليين وقد اطلق النار عليه وقتل في
المكان هذا بحسب وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه ومصادر شرطيه تؤكد ذلك في هذه
الساعه الان
الشرطه في مدينه تل ابيب تنتشر على نطاق
واسع في الاحياء وفي الشوارع القريبه من
موقع العمليه في محاوله لاقتفاء اثر ربما
المعاونين او ربما يكون هنالك شخص قد ساعد
منفذ العمليه على الوصول الى هذه المنطقه
وتنفيذ هذه العمليه